hallo ihr lieben schön dass wir zum
ersten video meiner ramadan hier
gefunden hat ich starte die reihe mit
kabarett ihre version ist allerdings
nicht klassisch sondern etwas aufgepeppt
zunächst benötigen wir drei eier 250
milliliter milch und 250 gramm
sonnenblumenöl die drei zutaten werden
jetzt mit dem schneebesen gut
miteinander verrührt für die erste
füllung benötigen wir 500 gramm
hackfleisch ich habe hier meine freunde
hut genommen
eine klein gewürfelte zwiebel 2 el
olivenöl sowie ein es mit martin marx
und ein ästhet afrika markt weiter
ausbauen ein team eben diese
paprikapulver einen halben teelöffel
verfahren einfluss des salz sowie ein
stilles kind als erstes geben wir das öl
in einer pfanne und dünsten die tribünen
waren
sobald die zwiebeln glasig sind werden
noch die knoblauchzehen hineingepresst
und ein paar sekunden lang mit gelüftet
danach wird das hackfleisch und
zugegeben und mit gebraten
[Musik]
sobald es hackfleisch venga ist kommt
tomaten und paprika marx hinzu und
werden mit gebrannten zu guter letzt
kommen da noch alle gewürze hinein
werden gut untergerührt und der mystic
bildung auch schon fertig für die zweite
füllung verwende ich ganz einfach
schafskäse da finde ich diesen hier am
besten ich habe mich durch alle
durchprobiert und der schmeckt super
lecker
das ist das sind 50 prozentige den ver
drücke ich dann einfach und dann ist die
zweite erfindung auch schon fertig wer's
mag kann auch noch klein gehackte
petersilie mithin zu tun und dann ist
die zweite führung auch schon fertig nun
benötigen wir fertigen teig das ist die
sau beach camp david stern bedeutet ganz
einfach dreieck team findet in jedem
türkischen supermarkt nun nehmen wir uns
einen youtube zeigt bestreichen das mit
der flüssigkeit die wir uns vorbereitet
haben geben dann großzügig von der
füllung hinein und rollen das ganze auf
gleiche machen wir dann mit dem
schafkäse hier auch die blätter vorher
mit der flüssigkeit bestreichen und
anschließend befüllen
[Musik]
zuerst werden die breiten seite nach
innen geklappt und dann wird das ganze
zu spitzen aufgerollt wundert euch nicht
wenn wir haben von der flüssigkeit noch
ein wörtchen bricht dies lag allerdings
werden dort hinein gepumpt und
anschließend in paniermehl gewählt in
der zwischenzeit könnt ihr euren ofen
schon auf 200 grad ober und unterhitze
vorhalten die fertig geräuschen und
panierten würdigt kommen dann auf ein
mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech und
werden anschließend ca 20 minuten
angewachsen
natürlich könnt ihr die bericht auch in
öl austraten darauf verzichte ich aber
denn das ist noch mal unnötig fed und
die schmecken so wirklich wunderbares
musste ich am besten genießt ihr sie
warm oder am nächsten tag nochmal in den
ofen schieben und dann schmecken sie
auch wieder wie frisch gemacht ich hoffe
sehr dass euch das erste video meiner
ramadan reihe gefallen hat denkt dran in
diesem sonderen monat gibt es jeden
zweiten tag ein neues video auf meinem
kanals und falls ihr noch nicht
abonniert habe dann holt dich bitte
gerne nach damit ihr auch nichts mehr
verpasst
[Musik]